permettez-moi de commencer par une question qui êtes-vous,
je veux dire vraiment suppose que je vous demande
personnellement ce que vous allez répondre Je suis un
avocat Je suis un psychologue AB peut-être que je suis une
mère ou je suis un étudiant souvent c'est
ainsi que nous nous définissons  dans la culture occidentale en
Afrique qui répondent
je suis du type loin ou Mahara et
d'ailleurs les palais sont assez similaires aux
Africains je ne me souviens pas combien de fois on
m'a demandé de la fille aqui para Long
Beach dont la fille êtes-vous
nous  pensez aussi en termes tribaux
et même s'il est partiellement vrai que
notre héritage, nos relations et
notre profession nous définissent, ce n'est pas ce
que je recherche aujourd'hui, je veux aller
plus loin au cœur de vous et moi, je
vais parler  à propos de l'identité et de la liberté,
vous devez être libre des
mentalités tordues et des circonstances déterminantes
afin de devenir la meilleure version de
vous-même. Moi-même, j'ai eu une seconde chance
de trouver la liberté en libérant ma véritable
identité.
dans une introduction typique
Je dirais quelque chose comme ça, je suis un
producteur de télévision en toast primaire à Kanellis
où j'ai eu le privilège de
diriger ma propre émission qui s'appelle visuel
et le visuel est un miracle en soi,
j'ai commencé avec rien d'autre que  une vision
puis un plan et c'était mon
seul objet physique dans le but d'
acquérir une énorme somme d'argent par
plusieurs sponsors au milieu de la
pause estivale en moins de sept semaines comme
sécurité financière de base pour
démarrer la production je  n'avait pas de vidéo
aucune expérience financière rien d'autre qu'un
désir ardent de produire une émission où l'
on passe sous le discours télévisé habituel au
cœur de l'être humain et cela a bien fonctionné
et je tiens à remercier Connor
pour cette opportunité cela a fonctionné  et
j'adore ça parce que les gens sont au centre, les
gens sont ma passion et donc à côté
de la télévision, je travaille comme
coach de vie et d'affaires. J'aime voyager
et surfer sur l'océan, c'est donc ça qui je suis.
à propos de ma
personnalité à propos de mon ta  carême et à propos de
mes compétences, mais supposons que je perds
mon travail à la télévision tout d'un coup, je détecte
que je souffre d'une maladie bizarre qui met ma
vie en danger. Je
ne peux plus faire de sport ni travailler
comme entraîneur au lieu de rester à l'hôpital.  au
bord de la vie elle-même que vous dirais-
je alors la vérité est que j'y suis allé
heureusement, cela ne s'est pas produit en
même temps mais j'ai vécu
ces expériences et je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre
vous aussi vous  ont traversé des
saisons difficiles et ils ne sont pas amusants, mais
il y a un capteur si vous le permettez, ils
vous enlèvent de
nombreuses couches peu profondes de la soi-disant
identité, le processus de vous libérer de l'
identité est accompli, mais après l'
une de ces saisons, c'est un  voyage de toute une vie
et ce soir, je veux partager quelques
révélations qui m'ont été confiées tout au
long de ce chemin jusqu'à présent et
j'aimerais vous donner quelques outils pour
vous libérer des mentalités tordues et
des circonstances déterminantes afin que vous puissiez
recevoir ces révélations et  quoique  Ces
outils que j'ai découverts et appliqués dans
ma vie personnelle et après d'excellents résultats,
je les ai testés dans la vie d'
autres personnes au travail,
car j'ai mentionné que les gens sont au
centre de ma carrière, ces outils ont donc
été confirmés par  de nombreuses personnes que j'ai
interviewées en tant que journaliste et qui ont
été prouvées par de nombreuses personnes que
j'ai soutenues en tant que coach de vie Je pourrais
vous raconter histoire après histoire mais j'ai
décidé ce soir que j'aimerais illustrer
ces outils sur mon expérience de vie personnelle
le premier outil que je te tends est une clé
une clé pour libérer cette révélation tu l'as
stockée avec un oui si tu veux
retirer quelque chose de cette
conversation acquiers cette certitude tu peux oublier
tout le reste mais garde celle-ci toi  J'ai
commencé par un oui, quelqu'un ou quelque chose d'
autre au-dessus de votre pouvoir vous a dit oui,
vous êtes une conséquence de cet acte puissant.
o  ne dans le corps, l'âme
et l'esprit et par cet acte unificateur que nous
appelons le sexe, vous êtes créé
quelle incroyable histoire parfaite de vous
vos racines sont aimées jusqu'au fond mais
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas aussi chanceux d'avoir un
genre aussi parfait peut-être que vous êtes un si  -appelé
accident ton père ou ta mère n'a pas prévu tu
me laisses te dire ce que ça n'a pas d'importance
il y a encore un grand oui derrière toi
il y a quelque chose hors de ton pouvoir
quelque chose qui existait avant ta
naissance si ce n'était pas ton  maman et papa,
c'était peut-être que si ce n'était pas Dieu,
c'était la nature elle-même, c'était peut-être un
seul spermatozoïde qui voulait survivre pour se
connecter pour créer la vie, c'était un oui en
dehors de votre pouvoir quelque chose qui est
plus grand que vous et laissez-moi ajouter  quelque chose
ici ce oui n'était pas là parce que
vous accomplissiez quelque chose ce oui est
inconditionnel au cœur de votre être
vous avez conçu pour l'amour inconditionnel et la
vie elle-même nous a donné cette sauvegarde
bien avant que notre cerveau ne soit le plus
développé pour argumenter le contraire et si
vous  voulez cette certitude plantée au
cœur de votre être vous avez besoin d'une clé en
particulier c'est la clé de la réception
il n'y a rien que vous puissiez faire mais recevez
ce oui inconditionnel
le changement des mentalités et des attitudes qui
vous retient de ce oui
mais
aussi l'ignorance et l'orgueil le seul moyen de se
libérer c'est d'avoir une
attitude enfantine et de recevoir ce oui inconditionnel le
reconnaître et dire merci
c'est alors que l'on commence à goûter à la liberté la
liberté de chercher constamment la
validation et l'approbation des autres
personnes parmi vous  sait que nous voulons tous
être aimés et acceptés nous avons besoin les uns des
autres
nous avons conçu pour nous connecter mais malheureusement
des schémas malsains et des mentalités tordues
ont créé une société où nous sommes
devenus esclaves les uns des autres ou précisément
esclaves des attentes vous pouvez
être esclave de votre  propres attentes que
ceux que vous pensez que les autres pourraient avoir
souvent c'est juste une fausse hypothèse
vous savez quand je  préparais ce
discours je pensais que tu voulais me faire
ce
merveilleux discours scientifique et ça n'a pas marché
ça n'a
pas marché  d'autres ont vraiment de
toute façon nous sommes comme des marionnettes
suspendues à des ficelles attachées à des
attentes et tout ce que les autres disent ou
pensent de nous influence la façon dont nous bougeons certains
d'entre nous plus certains d'entre nous moins mais nous tous
aussi et ne sous-estimons pas le pouvoir de
cela  motif c'est profond pourquoi parce que nous
sommes nés dans un système où l'acceptation
est basée sur une condition je suppose que lorsque
vous êtes un bébé comme si les gens étaient tous gentils
avec vous et aimer ça n'avait pas d'importance
si vous deviez pleurer comme si vous mourriez à tout
moment  ou souriez comme la chose la plus mignonne au monde
si vous avez toutes les chances de vous sentir
bien, cela m'est arrivé mais ensuite il
a changé plus je vieillissais plus
j'apprenais si mon comportement influençait
l'approbation des gens les
enseignants m'aimaient en fonction de mon
g  rade les garçons sur mon look et mes amis sur ma
personnalité extravertie et certaines
fêtes d'anniversaire ce modèle est profond et
contrarié par la glace nous avons besoin les uns des autres mais il y a une
différence entre fonctionner comme un esclave
ou gouverner comme un être humain libre et si
vous savez au fond de votre  cœur qu'il y
a un grand oui inconditionnel, vous n'avez pas
besoin de presser désespérément cela des
autres au contraire si vous savez
que vous pouvez facilement couper certaines chaînes d'
attentes, celles que vous pensez que les
autres pourraient avoir ou que les autres
vous ont vraiment  prêt à manipuler le prochain
outil le ciseau de la bravoure couper les
cordes demande du courage vous êtes courageux pour
aller dans cette direction parce que vous ne
connaissez pas le résultat
laissez-moi exposer cet appareil par un autre
exemple de ma vie personnelle en tant que jeune
adulte j'entendais beaucoup  tu es toujours
de bonne humeur tu es toujours heureux c'est
tellement amusant d'être avec toi bien en réalité
je ne me sentais pas heureux tout le temps j'avais aussi
des mauvais jours
mais d'une manière ou d'une autre inconsciemment j'ai choisi
Je me suis dit que je suis aimé parce que je suis toujours heureux de l'
amour conditionnel et que cela n'a fait
qu'influencer ma vie encore et encore,
ce n'était probablement pas le cas, une
fausse présomption typique, mais c'était mon
interprétation de leurs mots, donc je
n'ai jamais dit à personne que  Je passais une
mauvaise journée ou un chagrin d'amour douloureux et en
agissant de manière à couper des parties de
moi-même, je rejetais la douleur et ce
comportement intérieur se manifestait
par une condition physique appelée anorexie,
heureusement, seulement pendant une courte période,
mais j'ai fondamentalement  arrêté de manger
et c'était une manifestation physique de
mon rejet intérieur envers moi-même étant
la mauvaise humeur d'avoir une journée avant d'être un
gâchis et le seul moyen de s'en sortir était de
me libérer d'une chaîne appelée votre
loft parce que vous
riez toujours heureux et conditionnel et ici
il  vient
le César de la bravoure non décalé couper les
cordes demande du courage mais qui d'entre vous
sait cette citation étonnante une fois que vous devenez
intrépide la vie devient sans limite donc je
devais être courageux  e et pratiqué la
chose exacte dont j'avais le plus peur et en fait j'ai raconté que je
pratiquais d'être de mauvaise humeur
et étonnamment j'étais j'ai arrêté de
mettre le masque du
bonheur glorieux et des jours où je me sentais plus triste
découragé et étonnamment les gens
m'aiment de toute façon et ils  pouvez-vous l'essayer et la
plus importante de ces personnes est
moi-même si vous voulez vous libérer de
chaînes d'attentes, vous devez faire
la chose exacte dont vous avez le plus peur
peut-être avez-vous peur de dire connaître vos
sentiments la vie à d'autres  les gens parce que
vous avez des difficultés à dire non soyez
courageux dites non vous comprendrez que les gens comme
vous de toute façon et ce n'est pas votre affection
n'est pas réelle ils n'en valent pas la peine période
ce dont nous avons vraiment besoin ce sont les oui des
personnes capables  pour gérer notre nez
c'est ce dont nous avons besoin nous avons besoin de connexion
nous ne pouvons pas marcher seuls mais
inconditionnels et cela me mène à ma dernière
révélation circonstance ne définissez pas
votre valeur les Bijoux un symbole si puissant
pour vous et moi est le dernier  l'outil que
je vous tends il y a quatre ans j'ai été au
chômage jamais de toute ma vie j'ai
imaginé que cela pourrait m'arriver vous
savez que les choses ont plutôt bien fonctionné honnêtement
ma carrière même à l'école mes notes étaient
généralement des A plus tard j'ai été accepté dans
une école de théâtre  premier casting j'ai dormi très
facilement dans le journalisme mais cette
situation c'était différent c'était tout
un choc
et en plus à peu près tous mes
vêtements et tes amis allaient se
marier et déménager hors de la ville j'étais
seul et je n'avais pas de travail je  me sentais très
incomplet honteux et seul j'étais
absolument dévasté
et je me souviens si clairement du point bas
après trois mois sans trouver d'emploi
j'ai été recruté dans un programme de travail par
le bureau du chômage c'était un programme
principalement pour les gens ne sont pas très modulés
donc moi étant  là, j'étais très sous-
exercé, je m'ennuyais et je me sentais tellement
mal placé cette situation et c'est à
ce moment-là que j'ai reçu un
outil précieux, un outil pour me souvenir d'une
vérité fondamentale.  tel qu'il m'a été remis par
un ancien collègue que j'ai rencontré au hasard pour
un café un jour, je lui ai dit que j'étais
juste réel et je lui ai dit que vous savez que j'ai
vraiment vraiment honte de ne pas avoir de
travail et d'être coincé dans ce programme
qu'il écoutait regardé  moi et dit que
tu es un bijou et qu'aucune circonstance ne
changera jamais ta valeur et cette seule
phrase a tout changé elle
me rappelait ma vraie valeur un bijou un
bijou est un symbole si puissant de ta
valeur qui de vous sait que si ce
bijou  est tout brillant présenté dans une
bijouterie ou caché dans un garage sombre
sa valeur ne change pas si ça
vaut un dix millième avec des amis dans la
bijouterie ça ne va pas s'inverser si
vous le cachez dans votre sale garage sombre
circonstance ne le faites pas  définissez votre valeur,
votre valeur reste la même et saviez-vous
également que pour qu'une
pierre précieuse brute non taillée devienne la lunette brillante,
un artisan doit couper au moins
50% l'hiver dernier, j'ai visité le Sri Lanka, l'
île des bijoux
que j'ai  regardé t  les artisans du tuyau pendant
qu'ils polissent et trempent ces
pierres précieuses, c'est un fait que la tâche d'une gemme
est coupée afin de briller au
mieux,
je pense et les saisons difficiles, cela nous aide à
nous rappeler que nous ne devenons que la
version la plus splendide et la plus magnifique
de  nous-mêmes une fois que nous nous sommes abandonnés au
processus de coupe et aujourd'hui, je peux dire de
tout mon cœur que j'aime mon travail, c'est
tellement crucial et je suis tellement reconnaissant envers mes
amis et Sandee merci ici tu
comptes beaucoup pour moi mais je suis  pas enraciné
là ça peut tous dire Dawei et il y a
encore un gros gros oui inconditionnel derrière
moi la clé de la réception a permis
que sa certitude soit enracinée dans mon cœur
mais il y a des moments où j'oublie
cet amour inconditionnel pour en quelque sorte il a
glissé  en arrière-plan
et inconsciemment j'essaie d'obtenir cette
affirmation des autres ou de
moi-même et je suis à nouveau fort mais maintenant
j'ai un autre outil le ciseau de la
bravoure je peux me libérer en le
pratiquant exactement  J'ai le plus peur
et tu resteras libre en toutes saisons si
tu gardes la vision dans ta poche les
circonstances ne définissent pas ta valeur
ta valeur reste la même tu es un
miracle agit comme un
[Applaudissements]
toi